boiteau giovannini médecins et
chirurgiens ouverte audio m'anime
bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france cette
quarantaine a pu certainement dissuadé
de nombreux voyageurs qui souhaitaient
se rendre en italie la levée de cette
restriction prises pour soulager le
secteur du tourisme est elle raisonnable
au vu de la situation sanitaire en
italie - jour des bons images donc oui
effectivement la levée dès la 41e c'est
le soulagement
aussi mes mains à ce titre personnes
âgées des fascias je vais soigner
instance et qui sont finies la rentrée
chez pias one in italy et c'est vrai ça
veut dire garder l'effet de venir parce
qu'ils sont obligés même avec un test
négatif cinq jours d des 41 à titre
individuel
philippe fiduciaire sas qui ont demandé
des régions isolées en serrant le code
qui est aujourd'hui en italie la
campagne des vaccins bien progressé les
la tension au niveau aérien et des
hospitalisations d'un train de passer
aussi la présence cours leurs pertes et
qu'il ait négligé pour décider la
couleur dirigeante utermann données ce
qui est pour le moins les indicateurs
sont plutôt positifs sur la maîtrise de
la vague du lac simcoe but est de le
coter activités économiques
la saison estivale est arrivé et on sert
un code que l'italie par rapport aux
pays concurrents comme la grèce ou
l'espagne
on mérite un sou les réservations pour
l'été dont les gouvernements sont même
plus des draghi essaie de faire des
choses pour bouger pour promouvoir s'il
allait les regnault économique d'une
secteurs qui étaient très touchés celui
du tourisme vous disais en une tendance
qui est à priori à la baisse pour les
contaminations
si je ne me trompe pas plus de 7000
nouvelles contaminations en moyenne sont
comptabilisés à chaque jour vous vous
constatez vous également en tant que
médecin quelle est la situation actuelle
dans les îles dans les hôpitaux italiens
vous qui est basé à milan oui je discute
tous les jours avec mes confrères
anesthésistes qui qui est avec moi dans
la clinique est aussi dans les
structures publiques
ils me disent que la tension par rapport
aux plats céréales lait beaucoup diminué
on maîtrise mieux la connaissance et les
traitements déco vite là où on encore du
retard et c'est l'ego point faible de la
médecine italienne c'est la médecine de
ville qui était paix engagé autant de la
première vague autant de la leasing et
même dans l'allée vaccination en france
par exemple les médecins généralistes
peuvent vacciner
i télé les vaccinations sont fêtés dans
des centres ce qu'on appellera vaccins
des séances maximum ne sont pas faits
par les médecins généralistes donc c'est
vrai que l'on est en train de discuter
aussi une réforme de la médecine de
ville à 150 km signe de vie des
ministres aux bureaucrates et ce n'est
pas ce que je m'en faut pouvoir faire
une sorte de tampon entre l'hôpital et
la ville
du coup la vaccination finalement on
pourrait aller plus vite c'est ce que
vous nous dites si jamais les médecins
de ville pouvait aussi vacciner et ce
n'était pas réservé uniquement à ces
endroits dont vous nous parler ses
centres de vaccination oui disons
qu'elle met à mal à rattraper et
finalement de l'organisation l'a prise
et rendez vous a permis de rattraper le
retard
disons qu'elle en médecine de ville leur
permet d'aller d'être à plus avancé est
actuellement menace cela concerne plutôt
très bien et les taux de vaccination
commence être très haut et là par
exemple dans la région de lombardie en
voilà la vaccination matches joués au
moins des d'être un temps donc on vise à
voir toute la population de la région de
bahr d'y être il faut savoir que
l'italie
chaque région d'un peu d'autonomie aussi
sur la politique santé et pour la
lombardie on vise à arrêter d'avoir
toute la population de lombard de
patiner alors qu'on avait beaucoup je
suis médecin j'ai réussi une deuxième
phase
il ya dix jours une dernière question
alberto giovanni le ministre de la santé
est là aussi donc cette levée de la
quarantaine aux voyageurs en provenance
de l'union européenne mais aussi de la
grande bretagne
on sait que le variant indien
prolifèrent la baille
est ce que c'est bien raisonnable selon
vous alors la main à mon opinion mais
qui j'ai partagé déjà eu des soucis sous
le variable
parce qu'il ya des avions qui ont
atterri des deux à l'italie alors
qu'elle connaissait déjà la sortie de la
rade d'hyères
on a laissé le peule et malinké trop
large
après par l'angleterre effectivement il
y a un discours de la barrière indienne
keepcall offert à l'angleterre il faut
dire aussi parce que l'angleterre
ils ont beaucoup progressé sur la
campagne vaccinale est en tout cas même
moment c'est qu'ils proviennent
d'angleterre
il doit démontrer d'avoir un test kobe
négatif qui datent de moins de 48 heures
donc il ya un mort -une certains filtres
qui est fait par rapport à ça près
effectivement à c'est toujours un
équilibre entre faire venir les curistes
anglaise qui sont très importants pour
l'économie italienne
mais vite et aussi la propagation de la
dre blanc à terme le site ou le tchèque
est plus là la population italienne et
maxime est finalement à risque de
propager monde arabe indienne
même si c'est vrai que je l'écouté votre
émission l'italie on l'a presque
abandonné l'utilisation de barcelone
qu'à la faveur du trailer merci ouverte
et de vanille ni merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions se rappelle que vous êtes
médecin chirurgien